do you think i should have told them
potterheads get ready to discover some
of the darkest
best kept secrets about the harry potter
world jk rowling and the cast have made
some jaw-dropping revelations since the
series came to an end but many have
remained well hidden
so we're using our very best lumos spell
to shine a light on all the most
fascinating little-known details
i'm ready ask me any question dan
radcliffe
interviewed jk rowling for a special
feature on the deathly hallows part 2
dvd
and the author said that the original
plan was for the main trio to survive
but then midway through the series which
reflects she wasn't in a happy place at
the time
she started thinking she might polish
one of them off out of sheer spite
and it would have been wrong but in her
absolute heart of hearts she couldn't
just imagine the fan backlash if she'd
gone through with it and you don't know
how it feels
just imagine if we'd ended up with a
different actor playing ron
halfway through the series it seems
impossible but rupert grant admitted in
an interview with the independent that
he almost quit after goblet of fire
he explained that he just finished his
gcse exams
and thought to himself do i actually
want to keep doing this
it's a bit of a drag he considered it a
big sacrifice losing his anonymity and
not being able to do normal stuff
the actor described life as a little bit
scary at that point
thank goodness he didn't go through with
thinking he was done there's
only one ron weasley who do you imagine
wants to attack
children like yourself dolores umbridge
is one of the characters jk rowling
feels
purest dislike for but that doesn't mean
she didn't create a fascinating
backstory for her
on pottermore rowling revealed that
despite claiming to be a pureblood
umbridge actually had a muggle mother
and her brother was a squib
umbridge despised her father for his
lack of ambition
however when she was 15 dolores remained
with her dad when the family split as
they both blamed her mom for her
brother's lack of magical ability
does that information make you view
umbrage in a new light
i really hate children we were relieved
that arthur weasley survived nagini's
attack at the ministry of magic in the
order of the phoenix but jk rowling had
planned for that to be the end of him
she revealed to the today show that he
got a reprieve because she couldn't bear
to part with him as there are very few
good fathers in the book the author
believes you could make a case for
arthur being the only good father in the
whole series
but his survival was at lupin's cost
without whom
i would not be here as jk rowling
changed her mind about mr weasley she
felt she had to do away with a different
father and that was poor remus lupin
can you imagine what this series would
have been like if lupine had survived
but arthur hadn't
the author didn't take lupin and tonks's
fate lightly in 2016 she tweeted that
because arthur lived
lupin had to take his place she added
i'm sorry i didn't enjoy doing it
the only time my editor ever saw me cry
was over the fate of teddy
i wouldn't be standing here without him
jk rowling did away with lots of parents
in her books but she clearly feels a
sense of responsibility for the orphan
she created in an interview with the
today show the author revealed that she
wrote the 19 years later epilogue to
show that the world was a better place
and there was new life
and that was particularly for teddy
lupin's sake he was in that epilogue
kissing bill and fleur weasley's eldest
daughter victoire
at king's cross station rowling wanted
to show the readers that he was okay and
must be quite happy
there is a plot to make most terrible
things happen
of all the tragic ends that jk rowling
wrote dobby's fate
upset many fans i didn't mean to offend
you or anything
but guess what the author actually said
sorry to fans for what she did to the
wonderful house elf
just like she did about lupin rowling
has stood by most of her character's
endings despite fan reaction
but on the anniversary of the battle of
hogwarts in 2018
she took to twitter to apologize for
dobby's demise if only she'd had a
change of heart before the book had been
published
dobby feels most aggrieved sir the harry
potter universe included gothic
creatures like werewolves but never a
vampire teacher
however that very nearly did happen in
an article on pottermore in december
2014
jk rowling revealed that she toyed with
the idea of a vampire teacher called
trokar
but that got edited out rowling put paid
to fan chatter about snape being a
vampire too
even though he has an unhealthy pallor
and is sometimes described as looking
like a huge bat
in an interview with rte in 2011 alan
rickman revealed that jk rowling had
given him one little piece of
information
about how to play snape and he never
shared it with anyone
after he passed away rowling shared it
on twitter in january 2016
i told alan what lies behind the word
always of course she's referring to the
moment dumbledore asks snape if he's
still in love with lily
and snape replies always so rickman knew
what was motivating his character
all along come on tom let's finish this
the way we started
harry and voldemort were connected
through the horcruxes but did you also
know they were connected through their
family trees
wait what jk rowling revealed this
fascinating piece of info when she gave
us an insight into the potter family
harry's dad james inherited the
invisibility cloak from his ancestor
ignatus preverel and tom riddle was also
related to the previous family that's
why he had the resurrection stone
although there are hints in the deathly
hallows it wasn't made
explicit that's who we really are
of course authors often take inspiration
from people they've met
and jk rowling is no different in a
pottermore article she revealed that she
based dolores umbridge on a couple of
people
one was her teacher who loved twee
accessories including little plastic bow
slides
she wore sickly sweet and girlish
clothes with frills
and carried undersized handbags as for
the kitten pictures that was inspired by
a bigoted spiteful woman rowling shared
an office with
the author noted that a love of all
things saccharin often seems present
where there is a lack of real warmth or
charity
imagine being one of those women and
discovering you were part of the
inspiration for such an unpleasant
character
you know deep down
you deserve to be punished if you
thought rita skeeter would have changed
her ways
think again on the pottermore site jk
rowling wrote a report on the quidditch
world cup in 2014
in character as rita and the gossip
columnist was still making nasty jibes
at harry ron and hermione
commenting on their aging hair she also
kept up her habit for unpleasant
speculation
noticing a cut on harry's face rita
wondered if ginny had cursed him and if
there were problems in their marriage
typical you two may even make the front
page
there are so many major characters jk
rowling disposed of without regret but
guess what
she felt bad about the end she wrote for
a very minor character
florian fortescue the owner of the ice
cream parlor on diagon alley who was
dragged away by voldemort's servants
in the half blood prince go figure on
pottermore rowling revealed that
although fortescue wasn't the first
wizard voldemort disposed of for knowing
too much he was the only one she felt
guilty about because it was all her
fault
fortescue was going to be the conduit
for clues to help harry search for the
deathly hallows but rowling then decided
phineas nicholas black was a much more
satisfactory option
he must not be seen if you thought
dumbledore always looked like he could
see harry when he was under the
invisibility cloak you're right
jk rowling revealed in a web chat on the
bloomsbury site that dumbledore could
perform
magic without needing to say the
incantation out loud and what spell was
it that he used
hominem revellio hermione used the human
presence revealing spell in the deathly
hallows
in a deleted scene from deathly hallows
part 1 we finally get to see aunt
petunia in a more human light
or at least we would have done had it
not been cut as harry is saying his
final farewells to the dursleys he has
an exchange with his mom's sister that
reveals she didn't entirely dislike lily
yes petunia was envious and unkind but
she also kept loving lily deep down
had this scene made the final cut it
would have given us a different view on
the character
i lost the sister
which of these secrets changes the way
you view the harry potter series the
most
we want to know what you think but as we
aren't magical enough to read minds
you'll have to tell us in the comments
section instead
thanks for watching